[Music]
hello and welcome to quad Riga this
Saturday is international Holocaust
Remembrance Day the murder of more than
6 million Jews by the Nazi regime is a
defining fact of Germany's post-war
identity and the country has worked to
confront it yet anti-semitic attacks are
on the rise in Germany the political
ascent of the right-wing nationalist AFD
party now represented in Parliament is
provoking deep concern among Germans and
in Jewish communities so too is the
recent influx of Muslim immigrants a
recent study by the American Jewish
Committee documents widespread
anti-semitism amongst them in one widely
reported incident last year a Jewish
pupil the grandson of Holocaust
survivors quit his Berlin high school
after suffering mobbing and abuse at the
hands of Arab and Turkish classmates
living in fear how anti-semitic is
Germany that's our topic this week on
quadriga
and here are our guests it's a pleasure
to welcome Christine Hill Berg she's a
freelance journalist who recently wrote
a book about Syrian refugees in Germany
and the fears and prejudices they evoke
she says Germany needs a more inclusive
memorial culture and more backbone in
the fight against all forms of
marginalization and we're very pleased
to have Alan Posner on the show once
again he's a commentator for the daily
newspaper developed he says Jews
everywhere are held responsible for
every real or imagined injustice
perpetrated by Israel and finally very
glad to welcome Wenzel Mycoskie to the
show he's the director of Human Rights
Watch and he has experienced the problem
we're talking about firsthand
he says anti-semitism in Germany is
escalating and increasingly normalized
and the state is responding to slowly
ham moshevsky it was indeed your son who
suffered the abuse that I referred to at
the opening of the show would you tell
us a little bit about what happened
there yeah he was new at the school and
at the end of the first week a teacher
asked what kind of world religions do
you guys know
and what kind of houses of worship so
the student said church mosque and and
it was my son's turn and he said
synagogue and the teachers are you
Jewish and he said yes and that is when
everything started the attack started
and what exactly was everything started
with verbal abuse and bullying and but
then also physical attacks he was beaten
very badly and at his hands other
students did this and he was also there
was a mock execution and that was the
point when we took him out of the school
roughly three months later other
students according to many newspaper
reports especially Arab and Turkish
fellow students is that correct in this
case it is correct
mostly Turkish and also Arabs and he was
not the only one who was bullied Kurdish
black gay students and girls were also
badly abused and the school did nothing
and but in his case because he was
Jewish it was extremely it was in worse
because they didn't beat up other kids
now your opening statement indicates
that you definitely don't see this as an
isolated phenomenon and yet the
government's anti-semitism report and
more or less quoting here comes to the
conclusion that in comparison with any
other time before world war two or
thereafter open anti-semitism has rarely
been less tolerated by the broad
majority of society than today so how do
you reconcile that statement with what
your child experienced well firstly we
Germans have learned how to answer
questions about anti-semitism and no
German would say I'm anti-semitic or I
hate Jews
so people find their learnt in rituals
in remembrance days in all this how to
how to answer these questions so they
don't appear anti-semitic but they are I
mean the fact that the management of the
school the headmaster didn't do anything
to protect my son Eve
after we asked him again and again shows
yeah pretty big resentment against Jews
because otherwise this person would have
been alarmed or the whole school or in
fact also the people who were
politically responsible for the school
and we have learned from other people
from other schools in Dusseldorf in
cream and Frankfurt Munich and so on so
forth
similar incidents because now people
because isn't public now people come out
and talk about it
Alan Posner the same report that I just
quoted from the German government
although it admits that attitudes or
says that attitudes amongst the broad
majority haven't changed it does admit
that there's increased anti-semitic
activity in the words of the report in
terms of propaganda verbal and physical
abuse so what exactly is going on there
are we seeing a minority on the margins
of society that feels increasingly
empowered to act out um there is that
this is you know anti-semitism is a
multifactorial thing I mean stupid to
say that but it's true there are use of
if you like traditional real
anti-semites
who some are may feel emboldened by the
internet for instance social media there
are the new anti-semites who call
themselves anti globalists who are
situated within the so-called
alternative for Germany this new party
they never say they're against Jews but
it's always the east coast the
capitalists and then it's Goldman Sachs
or whatever and somehow it all boils
down to the old enemy and then there is
something which is on the left and in
among Muslim the Muslim community which
is anti-zionism and ever since 1967 the
you know the 68 has my generation they
were so proud they said what we
confronted our parents about what they
did in the Nazi past that is true - up
to a point but then they turned round
and supported Arab terrorism against
Israel they wrote you know the the Red
Army Faction actually trained in
Palestinian terror camps and so on and
since then it's sort of a
if you're on the left that you're
critical of Israel yeah there's there's
you know there's no acceptance the fact
that Israel is the only democracy that
gays lesbians and so on queers
transgender people you know it's and so
this all comes together these three
aspects Kristin Harbor would you agree
are we seeing a rise in intolerance
generally and particular in
anti-semitism I think what has really
changed is the climate in Germany of
public discussions of private
discussions a lot of things are being
said that would have been impossible ten
years ago fifteen years ago and this
doesn't go only for anti-jewish
resentments but it goes for anything
that is considered different that is
considered alien to German somehow we
have this growing sentiment of
everything should stay as it is
Germans are one nation and they look
like this and they act like this and
whoever comes here has to be act like
this into this kind of assimilation so
it goes not only against Jews it goes
especially against Muslims right now
this is like if we if you read sometimes
texts of nowadays if you replace the
word Muslim with Jewish it gets really
frightening to me you know we have this
kind of stigmatization that always is
the beginning of further development to
more violent reactions towards
minorities the stigmatization of my own
minorities this is a big problem inside
Germany I want to talk about what
effects that changing climate has and we
have a short film about that in recent
years Berlin has actually seen something
of a rebirth of Jewish life but could
this increasingly be perceived as a less
than welcoming place we can listen now
to the voices of vensim Mashav sqeeze
children interviewed for a film called
because you're a Jew that we're showing
on DW I always felt it was better not to
say I'm Jewish really yeah yeah I don't
see that way yeah I hardly told anyone
not at university either I don't keep
quiet about it
to me that would feel like it's
something I should be ashamed about even
if that's not how it is for you as if it
were a secret
oh I'm Jewish if other people don't like
it that's their problem is this mind
probably has the mobbing experience that
your son went through changed the
children's attitude and if you look
toward the young Israelis who in the
past years have been coming to Berlin
with great alacrity would you say to
those thinking about coming better stay
away no I wouldn't say better stay away
but I would say brace yourself be aware
to what kind of City and what kind of
country you're coming to and look really
carefully in which area you want to live
but I think most Israelis who are coming
to Germany are aware of these things I
can't imagine anybody from all countries
than the world that I want to resettle
to Germany that they haven't thought
about that but in your own kids have
their attitudes changed I don't think
their attitudes have changed because
they were always aware of this my
daughter as we have seen says I rather
hide being Jewish she's studying in
England in England there is especially
at universities there is a very lively
anti-semitism at the moment and my son
he studies in the US and there's not
such a big problem with anti-semitism so
they see it from their own point of view
but it has changed my son my wife and me
and my parents very much we see this
country now with different other eyes
your parents of course being Holocaust
survivors yes Alan Posner let's talk
about the link which you mentioned
between criticism of Israel and
anti-semitism where and when does the
one begin to shade into the other and
would you say given Germany's crimes
that German simply should
refrained from criticizing Israel
altogether oh of course not look Israel
is a country like every other so it's a
country which makes mistakes maybe even
commits crimes and these can be
criticized the thing is there's a
there's a word in Germany called Israel
critique one word right which means
criticism of Israel there's not no such
thing as shall we say franchise critic
or it's only aimed at the Jewish state
and a state which declares itself
Jewish and if you ask where does it
shade over there's a very clear
definition which has been accepted by
the European Committee European
community and by the German government
and this is it's the three DS
demonization D legitimacy and double
standards if you hold Israel to a higher
standard than you would another country
in that critical security situation if
you demonize Israel as being some kind
of apartheid state if you D legitimize
it by saying you know we're gonna
boycott academics from your country but
you don't do with regard to China or
Russia or other countries this is where
Israel critique becomes anti-semitism
obviously criticism of Israel was much
in evidence at a demonstration in
December that was amongst the incidents
fueling fear of a rise in anti-semitism
in Germany let's take a look at a
demonstration that took place in Berlin
after Donald Trump's announcement that
the US would move its embassy to
Jerusalem pro-palestinian demonstrators
chanted death to Israel and earned
Israeli flags now Christian hilberg at
those protests cameras did capture young
men of Arab origin sitting on each
other's shoulders and shouting and
chanting a recent report from the
American Jewish Committee I mentioned it
briefly earlier documents some pretty
egregious expressions of anti-semitism
among Arab immigrants in Germany so your
opening statement says that
backbone is needed but what kind of
backbone is needed here in this case our
Arab immigrants who've come in the past
couple of years part of the reason we're
seeing this trend to greater intolerance
there's a big problem of anti-semitism
among Arabs or Turkish youngsters I
fully agree but we have to make an
important difference between people who
were born here as second or third
generation young people were raised here
who went to German schools and who
should have learned some political rules
and some self understandings of Germans
not only concerning anti-semitism but
what is written in the very German
Constitution that nobody should be a
privileged or should be neglected for
his religious for his religion or ethnic
background so the the other story is
refugees who have come here during the
past two years for example from Syria in
Syria there is a political problem with
Israel Israel is until now occupying the
Syrian Golan Heights so Syrians have
learned all their lives that Israel it's
the enemy and that it should be fought
against so this is the narrative that
these young people come to Germany with
and this cannot be changed easily in
some integration course this needs time
and they have other problems when they
come here because there's a lot of
problems about integration and finding
work and learning the language but what
really really is a big problem for me is
when people who grow up here and have
went to German schools still have this
anti anti-semitic but command
anti-muslim ng against everything that
is considered to be different that is a
big problem for me and there we have
failed and we have a structural problem
problem inside Germany among Germans
original by you of you Germans and
people with migration background and we
have to confront this by different means
maybe as well by a different culture of
remembrance of the Holocaust I want to
come in just a moment to the culture of
remembrance but let me just ask you
Venson moshevsky would you say that
Angela Merkel's open-door policy has in
fact
paved the way for this rise in
anti-semitism and have we in a way
imported the Middle East conflict right
here into the heart of Germany well the
first question I would say not at all
the people we've seen here demonstrating
mostly people who came here a long time
ago they're politicized there are
activists Hamas is behind those people
we see them
a regular basis on anti Israeli
demonstrations here in Berlin and I mean
you know we Germans have to grow up that
these people are here in Germany and we
have to deal with this but what we
haven't dealt with is actually in
schools educating young Germans and
Muslims in a smart way how and mostly
those are German muslin and to see this
I mean mostly German muscles because
they were born already in Germany they
have so the call of some conservative
party members here in Germany to expel
all foreign Muslims is very
short-sighted because it puts the finger
only on a on a certain group which we
have to deal with of course but which
does not represent all the Muslims in
Germany also this is the effort to
educate has of course been part of an
effort here in Germany to come to terms
to confront the crime of the Holocaust
there's even a special word for it for
ganyan Heights Bavetta gong
confrontation with the past and one
example of that phagon heights parvati
gong is the culture of remembrance
including a monument that remembers the
Holocaust just a few kilometers from
here the memorial to the murdered Jews
of Europe it took a good 25 years for
the plans to be brought to completion
it's location in Berlin's government
district is perhaps the most visible
indication of Germany's intent to face
up to its history unobtrusive in
contrast are what are called stumbling
stones they reflect the everyday horrors
of the Nazi era and commemorate Jews who
were deported murdered or driven out
tens of thousands have been placed all
across Germany and Europe making them
the world's largest decentralized
memorial and then there are the places
of horror themselves such as a schvitz
today it's a memorial site that makes
the nazis machine of genocidal
destruction tangible to visitors what is
the right form of remembrance el khazneh
the former German President Joachim
Guk's
[ __ ] said two years ago there is no
German identity without outwits
remembering the Holocaust remains a
concern for all citizens who live in
Germany but can we really expect
migrants to Germany to share that view
and also perhaps very young Germans who
say hey that's so long ago well there's
two aspects to this the first aspect is
this is not a German question the
Holocaust was and remains something that
is that is important for every person
everywhere in the world whether you're a
German whether you're a Jew whether
you're a German Jew whether you're a
German Muslim whether you're an American
you they have a Holocaust Memorial in
Washington DC why they have a Holocaust
Museum in Los Angeles why because this
is something which we all need to think
about so it's not a question of can we
expect sort of my grandchildren to take
responsibility given that you know that
the great grandfather was a Jews of
course we can can we expect you Muslims
of course we can't because every human
being needs to understand that this kind
you know this crime is something that
must not happen again which leads us
again to Israel if you're talking about
Israel has no right to exist you're
talking about denying six million people
the right to exist which is precisely
what the Holocaust was
about we need to make this connection
that's the second problem because people
talk about the Holocaust yeah well it
must never happen again it's not gonna
happen again like that
it's gonna happen with an Iranian
missile on Tel Aviv it's gonna happen
with with you know with with with Jews
being with their synagogues being burned
by Arabs here in in in Germany it's
gonna happen in a different way and we
need to make that connection we have to
disconnect it a little bit from this
criticizing Israel I know you are saying
it is possible and it is necessary to
disconnect the positive Jewish yes where
the Jews went because the Germans threw
them out if they didn't kill them so
this is part of Holocaust Remembrance is
supporting Israel there's no way you can
know but then it's very difficult for
people for example who come from Syrian
who perceive Israel as an enemy and if
you talk about Palestinians who are
being occupied and who are being taken
their rights from by this very State of
Israel to criticize this this nut must
be possible by anyway and this and it's
not so easy to say you know that
anti-israel or aristocratic is equal to
anti-semitism is equal to anti-zionism
you know for me we have to by mixing up
these things this makes it more
difficult look I'm not honestly I'm
perfectly sympathetic with a Palestinian
who says I lost my grandparents lost
their home and so on and and I can't be
expected to like Israel but when he says
we're going to go back one day and this
is going to be part of Palestine with
the with the flag and the Jews yahoodi
as they are gonna be gone then I say may
I just really sorry they say it all the
time
may I interrupt here because I would
like to come back to the culture of
remembrance and ask you chrysten Helberg
after those December protests that we
saw the pictures of there were calls
from a number of people for there to be
mandatory visits to Remembrance sites
such as concentration camps for those
young Muslims in Germany you said we
have a problem particularly with young
Muslim men including young Muslim men
who have been here for quite some time
would that be a good idea
would that make a difference anything
mandatory with teenagers will not work
that's a very important point I think it
would be very good if people come to
the point that they would like to go
there to confront this history and I
very much agree with mr. Posner that
this is not a German thing that it's an
international on an historical and
international scale
a crime against humanity and it has to
be remembered like this and this is the
big chance for me if we consider this
part of German identity then we have to
make it more inclusive for whatever
lives in Germany nowadays Germany has
changed Germany is an immigration
country it's supposed to be an
integration country so we have to talk
in schools in a different way about the
Holocaust it shouldn't be just a chapter
in the history class but it should be
connected with what happened in the
Middle East after that's what at that
time was going on there how did people
all regimes position themselves to this
what was the outcome of this Holocaust
in Europe concerning Palestinians and
their being you know for even and being
out of exile from their country so by by
connecting this with other countries
make it more international the way of
talking about it we keep it as one
important pillar for German identity
Vincent Michel scheme what do you think
needs to happen the former head of the
Central Council of Jews in Germany has
called for the federal government to
create a new authority that would
monitor and defend against the rise of
anti-semitism as we've said there have
been calls for mandatory visits to
concentration camps what steps do you
think need to be taken now here in
Germany I think the fact that we will
have a special envoy a Special
Rapporteur on anti-semitism is a good
step in the right direction the other
subject I must say that we are very good
in Germany in remembering and in
creating memorials we are world
champions but the danger is that we have
hidden our present-day
anti-semitism that's still there under
those memorials we have to deal much
more with present-day anti-semitism and
the anti-semitism of those people who
would do regard themselves as anti
enticing it cymatics and/or anti-racists
because
that is sometimes just a label and under
the surface it's still boiling so how
how would you want to do that what do
you do for example with the shoe with
the school director who clearly didn't
get what was going on in his school yeah
I think there has to be accountability
this guy is still the director of the
school and what can happen to him the
worst can happen that he is the transfer
to another school then other people have
to deal with him though there has to be
a accountability and the schools and the
teachers they have to be prepared and
trained to deal with these problems and
they are not at the moment and they just
put the head in the sand and that's it
let me briefly come back to our title
and ask all of you in one word if you
look at the rest of Europe the rest of
the world how anti-semitic is Germany
it's sort of middling I think it's not
more into semantics than the rest of the
world but bad enough I think that's
actually not the question the question
is how is Germany dealing with the
existing anti-semitism right now doesn't
matter
by whom and not well enough according to
you thank you very much to all three of
you for being with us today and thanks
to all of you for tuning in please do
watch the film because you're a Jew that
we are showing in VW thanks so much
[Music]